for
a notification in the chat feed if we
are live
yes chairman you're live thank you okay
thank you good afternoon and welcome to
this performance governance and audit
committee meeting which is our first
virtual meeting today thursday 25th of
june
2020 my name is councillor mrs elaine
bamford
and i am the chairman of this committee
this is modern districts council's first
remote meeting of this committee
held under new regulations which came
into effect
on the 4th of april in response to the
kovid 19 situation
there are just a few housekeeping issues
to run through
including our new working practices
which have been
implemented due to the pandemic and the
etiquette for this meeting
first of all please could i ask everyone
present in this meeting to ensure your
microphone remains muted
and your video feed off when not
addressing the committee this will
reduce background noises
and avoid any unintentional disturbances
this meeting will be hosted remotely via
conferencing
software which allows members of the
public to virtually attend the meeting
whilst being able to protect themselves
and others and observe the government's
lockdown measures
we may encourage some glitches this suck
we may encounter sorry some glitches
this afternoon
so i hope that everyone will bear with
us as we get used to this new way of
working
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent
to being recorded members and officers
during
each item please use the chat function
of the meeting to indicate if you wish
to speak
i will then invite you at the
appropriate time
members are reminded that apart from
indicating you wish to speak
or that you have to leave the meeting
the chat function should not be used for
questions or other any other purpose
members the process this afternoon will
obviously be different
and for some items i may invite each
member to speak in turn
therefore i would encourage all members
to keep your contributions as clear
and concise as possible please when
speaking and referring to the agenda
papers
please ensure you reference a page or
paragraph
number could i also ensure that everyone
is directly connected to a power supply
so that nobody drops out
due to short battery life and lastly
if members need to leave the meeting at
any point please do make this known
and use the chat function to signify
that you need to leave the meeting
now if i may ask officers taking part in
the meeting to
introduce themselves starting with mr
paul dodson
good afternoon members i'm paul dodson
director strategy performance and
governance
thank you miss donnelly
do we have miss donna donnelly from uh
pdo no
uh mr holmes good aft good afternoon
members richard holmes director of
service delivery
um cheryl miss cheryl hughes
good afternoon members cheryl hughes
program performance and governance
manager
thank you cheryl um mr holly
good afternoon members i'm grant holly
i'm the lead ict specialist
thank you grant um mr chris leslie
good afternoon i'm chris leslie director
of resources
thank you chris and lastly bernard
werner casey who's going to help me with
the meeting
good afternoon members yes bernard clark
to the meeting this afternoon
thank you have we got any other members
present
burner any other officers sorry
officers we've got any any other
officers present
i don't believe so not at the moment i
just need to see if i can contact
miss donnelly thank you yes yeah thank
you thank you
um so berna can you now carry out a roll
call of members to confirm
who is in attendance thank you thank you
chairman
and councillor bamford obviously i'm
here
thank you councillor bs
feel we know council beat is here so i'm
just going to say yes
councillor mrs channer can you speak up
brian
hello brian speaking thank you
councillor mrs channer
hello yes i'm here councillor durham
present chancellor fluker
president sponsor howard
[Music]
the schemes
yes burner i'm present mr
thank you chairman thank you bernard
um have we got apologies for absence yes
we've had two
from councillor parker and councillor
keys
thank you now
members before we move to consider the
minutes
uh item three um i'd like to clarify
that
the audits on workforce management and
community safety
will form part of the agenda for our ex
committee
on the 30th of july and i also now would
like to hand over to the director of
resources
who's going to give us a verbal update
on the audit
of the statement of accounts i'll bring
you back
yes thank you madam
chairman the
draft statement of accounts was
published on the 31st of may
ahead of this year's deadline which is
the 31st of august this year due to
covert 19.
the external audit commenced on the 1st
of june
and is currently ongoing the deadline to
have the audited set of accounts
finalised this year is
the 30th of november currently the audit
is progressing well
with the audit team communicating with
the council staff and microsoft
teams and other methods remotely on a
daily basis
outstanding audit requests are
listed and that schedule is maintained
and reviewed
regularly there are no significant
slippages
or backlogs at this time with all
original audit queries
having been replied to auditors
are sampling at this moment which means
they are
selecting samples from a list
of for for example invoices they may
pick invoices
to sample and they are currently going
through
their selection process of those and
they will be
requesting more information from council
officers
soon so they can conduct those sample
tests
they currently have three more weeks to
go
on site as it were on virtual site until
the 10th of july and they will do some
follow-up work
after that with a view to having
everything finalized towards the end of
july
audit have confirmed that they are still
on schedule to do this
currently and obviously we're reviewing
that on a daily basis
thank you thank you very much for that
update
um we won't have questions on that
members
um so i want to move on to the minutes
now
of the 27th of february which i hope you
will have looked at um so it's
recommended that the minutes of the
meeting
held on the 27th of february 2020 found
on pages
5 to 16 are approved as a true and
accurate record
i so move if you wish to second that
please turn on your video
unmute your microphone and state your
name now thank you
second i can't thank you
who who was that um banner who's second
did we
i think councilman might have been first
or jarvis i've seconded as well but i
think they came in before me
thank you um so
does any member wish to raise any matter
of accuracy
please use the chat function and i'll
invite you to speak
berna is there anyone on the chat
function
questioning the accuracy no no
chairman not of the minutes
so um are we happy members to take the
vote
um on maths rather than going through
the individual pages
if everyone's happy with the minutes
agreed thank you very much
thank you so we'll go on to
declarations of interest and i'll read
this out
i'm sorry that i'm not looking at the
screen because i have to look at another
screen to read it out
to disclose the existence and nature of
any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
pecuniary interests or non-pecuniary
interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraphs six
to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
members are reminded that they are also
required to disclose
any such interests as soon as they
become aware
should the needs arise throughout the
meeting
if any member has an interest to declare
please use the track function now
to indicate and i will invite you to
speak
berna have we got any members wishing to
declare an interest
please
i do madam chairman well there's nobody
in the chat
feed madam chair i'm sorry i forgot to
put it there i thought that's okay
your counselor mrs chandler is now in
there i forgot to press the arrow
no problem sorry
madam chairman i'm going to be declaring
um
non-pecuniary as a member of essex
county council because within the
reports there is mention
um of essex county council
certainly in the performance one it
refers to health
um issues um and primary schools and
essex county council has been named in
those
so therefore any areas within any of the
reports which might relate in any way
or remit of county council i'm declaring
that non-pecuniary
thank you councillor janna anyone else
wish to declare an
interest in any of the items on the
agenda council durham has indicated
thank you chairman um also as a member
of essex county council and
non-pecuniary interest uh
for items relating to the county council
thank you
thank you councillor don
anyone else nobody else chairman
thank you okay our next item on the
agenda
is five public participation
and i can advise that we've not received
any submissions from members
of the public so the next item is item
six the internal audit reports now have
we got
miss donnelly now in attendance
the chair i've been trying to use the
chat function
council of banford and it hasn't worked
i actually do have a question
as a member of the public please
okay fine
can you use the track function now
accounts counselor morris
we've been trying to use it i've got one
i did ask
to use a question on it earlier but
since then i haven't been able to
really use it for some reason it's just
i can type i can't
does your question relate to any item on
the agenda because
you are a counsellor in this meeting so
i remember the public
i'm asking this is a member of the
public and it's uh item seven
item seven yeah
which is the corporate performance yes
all right so you want to raise an item
as a member of the public not as a
counselor because you could uh
you could have asked at the beginning of
the meeting if you wanted to speak as a
counselor
i did put that i had a question uh
i am a little bit how can i put it
reticent about
um asking questions as a counsellor
because i'm usually ignored
so well as i can assure you councilor
morris that as
a a councillor on modern district
council
with this committee you would not have
been
denied that opportunity as a councillor
but you haven't done that so if you want
to raise something
in public participation that relates to
an item on the agenda then please do so
now i apologize
chairman but the procedure does require
advanced notification
via the microsoft form process but
obviously that's
a chair's descript chairman's discretion
okay thank you
i understand that um understand that but
i think we will let councillor morris
speak thank you
thank you very much councillor bamford
and uh i'd just like to say that i do
have
respect for yourself you've been very
kind um
you're a very good chair so uh you get
the respect you deserve
um i'd just like to um point out that um
i believe that
this council is failing some small
and medium-sized businesses in the
current cod19 crisis
by not
giving them enough information on grants
or
coming forward with the grants in time
to save
employment and businesses at this time
um
i've been contacted by a few small
businesses
are we going to be able to help them
adequately
myself as a counselor i'm struggling to
get any answers
whatsoever from my own council
thank you all right thank you for that
councillor morris we will pass that on
so we're moving on to then item six on
the agenda which is internal audit
reports
um could we ask berna
have we got miss donnelly now in
attendance
[Music]
we're just checking chairman and she has
been resent the
invite and and we're just seeing if
she's managed to actually get into the
meeting she had no problem
with the agenda meeting so i'm not quite
sure i'm just checking the link again
and i will be back to you in
well i'm just wondering if we in that
case we should move on to
item seven end of year review of
corporate performance until miss
donnelly arrives because otherwise
if we have questions she's not going to
be available to answer them
if members are happy i think we will do
that until miss donnelly arrives
so we're going on um
is that okay sorry yes yes agreed
um so we go on to item 7
which is the end-of-year review of
corporate performance
in a moment i'll call on the officer to
present this item
members just remind you if you wish to
speak please make this known using the
chat
function uh and then we'll come to you
in turn
um so miss sheryl hughes will present
the report thank you okay good afternoon
members
i'm just going to load the presentation
there we're going to try to put you on
the spot um because it's come a bit
earlier in the agenda than
we had anticipated okay
okay so that should now be visible on
the screen um
so the report um presented is our first
end-of-year view of
corporate performance against the
corporate plan which obviously runs till
2022. um the strategic theme lead team
are currently reviewing the measures
associated with these corporate outcomes
and looking at which need to be revised
into 2021 in light of recent challenges
and developments that are brought about
from the covid
crisis um overall the performance
against the allocated measures for 1920
has been good
um but the header report draws attention
to specific areas for delivery concern
which i will now run through a print
appendix a provides an overall strategic
picture for each of the
thematic areas and these are available
at slides four which is the corporate
community
performance yeah thank you slides
10 which is the place performance and
slides 19 which is prosperity
the pages that then sit after each of
those headline pages break down the
specific measurements and supporting
work plans that back up delivery of the
measures
so for example pages 4 to 19 cover
everything
to do with the community theme within
the corporate plan
the commentary on the outcomes pages
provides context around how the measures
have performed to give an overview for
all corporate outcomes
so i'm going to take you now to slide 5
which is the community
performance headline view and this is
measure f
which is effective engagement to support
strong and resilient communities
and this is the first measure that
members attention is drawn to
um in terms of issues around delivery
the commentary text explains um about
the better care fund and payment of dfgs
and how they've been
impacted by covert but the data then
sitting behind this
is further shown on slide seven
here at the bottom so
that explains why for that particular
measure
we're flagging concerns in terms of
delivery
i'll then take you to the place
strategic performance
um in which there are three themes where
measures have been flagged
so these are d improved air quality
f sound and tested environmentally
friendly initiatives
and j which is section 106 planning
agreements being effectively discharged
so specifically for improved air quality
um there has been a delay to the
delivery of the strategy
although this is now scheduled to a
further commit a future committee date
um for the climb for the sound and
tested environmentally friendly
initiatives
um there is a climate change strategy
due but this has been re-prioritized due
to
officer work on covid19 and then
for measure j section 106 planning
agreements
um there's a lot of site closures due to
covid
so um that again has impacted on the
delivery there
there's further information to explain
again why those
um measures are tracking as they are um
in slides 15 16 and 17
which give more detail on the plans and
where the targets have
or haven't been met underneath those
measures
if i take you now to prosperity where we
have
one measure that sits outside of where
we'd expect delivery
so this is measure c rural business and
diversification supported
um there has been a change of scope for
this particular measure
because an spd was required for bradwell
but is no longer required
and also there are some details around
um the rural business district
delay and um being behind schedule there
which is impacted on this delivery so
further detail for this outcome
is available further down the slides in
the outcomes
uh in the supporting plans so
i just take you to slide 23 um
where so we're looking at measure c
rural and coastal businesses
um and again this is the
bradwell one and this gives further
detail about
um why that target hasn't necessarily
been met as expected
so members are invited to review the
performance report
and challenge the delivery of the
corporate plan outcomes
and the initiatives provided thank you
thank you very much for that
very interesting um presentation
obviously with the kovid we realize some
of the
outcomes are red but that's to be
expected but
bearing that in mind it seems quite a
good
report so questions
members berna have we got anyone that
wishes to
raise a question yes chairman counselor
jarvis would like to ask a question
okay councillor jarvis please go ahead
thank you chairman um i had three
questions one of which may have already
just been answered but they were
regarding the report
first is on page 70
chairman concerning open spaces
i i i i read with interest
point two which says due to future
council processing key vacancies within
service capacity
uh for review and writing of plan is
currently very limited
i just wondered if somebody could
comment further on that
do you want me to give the questions go
through the time
three questions do you want them one at
a time chairman i would go
through all three and then
thank you joe the second question i've
got page 71
with regards to air quality
and uh
i think there we have just heard some
comment on that
but i noticed that um
i wondered if we could be given some
more precise dates as to when
something might be done on that the
target was
to for completion december 2019 i just
wondered if more information could be
given
and the third item related to is on page
18
which relates to the rural coastal
business but i do believe
i think i withdraw my question on that
regarding what's happening because
i think we were we just had our
attention drawn to a detailed
explanation of that so
just the two questions chairman page 70
and page 71
open spaces and air quality
thank you councillor jarvis um sheryl
hughes may you
comment on those please i think they're
probably better for richard to pick up
which is why he's
thank you can i help the uh the question
there please
thank you no problem yes um essentially
around the capacity of the
team that lives after our open spaces
unfortunately is competing uh priorities
just at the moment um obviously our
long-term
aim is to have those management plans in
place they've very much been caught up
in operational matters and certainly
around covid
um since probably february this year um
but before that obviously we have been
through a complete structural change
within the council
um has meant there has been a delay and
it's just been compounded by covid
so um in this case that they're
certainly on the work prone to be done
but unfortunately we've not been able to
deliver them at this time
thank you are you commenting on the
second question as well yes could i just
ask that question to be put to me just
once more so i
fully understood the question if that's
possible please counselor jarvis could
we
yes i think that one was page 71 just
regarding air quality
i wasn't sure that i could see specific
dates as to when anything was actually
going to be done by
thank you yes um air quality and there
was a meeting of the working group this
week
um to actually review the report and
there will be a report coming to council
again there has been a delay in getting
that forward but it's been a very
comprehensive
uh consultation document we've had an
assurance that we believe it's a robust
process that we've been through
so you'll be seeing that coming to
council very soon
thank you thank you chairman um may i
just
ask mr holmes before you go um
do we know when that's coming to the
council
i believe it could be the second or the
sixteenth and i don't have the exact
date here but it's certainly
um certainly in july thank you
thank you very much um any other
questions from members berna
yes councilman mrs channel has a
question german okay
councillor china please
sorry chair and my my machine just went
then i've had to come back in using my
password and join the meeting again so
i've missed part of that i am sorry
and i've lost my papers so i'm gonna
have to do it from memory but
what i've noticed is um unless i can't
define the pages now unfortunately
a number of the red which show we
haven't met targets
on a number of them and one's to do with
health of older persons which is a
strategic priority um a number of them
are claiming
um that they haven't got uh there's not
enough resource
now and that's just a blanket thing it
doesn't mention covid or anything it
says about staff resource more than once
in some of these red
itemized things what i'd like to know
please
is that lack of resource because we
haven't got the staff
um because i i thought we were up to
sort of
quantifiable amounts that allowed our
resource to be okay
or is it um partly to do with code
although the report doesn't say that but
it keeps saying lack of resources and i
don't think it's just financial it
it seems to refer to bodies as in staff
i'd just like and i would perhaps like
to have an update on all that maybe
outside of the meeting on all those reds
just
how the resources are now if that can't
be answered at this time
thank you council china does any of the
officers wish to comment on that please
okay um mr holmes did
sorry yes yes chairman sorry i was
rapidly trying to turn on there
um yes um
i think where there are issues with
resources
there are largely to do with
either the the covid um issue
or um we are still operating slightly
under the um the full establishment
in terms of the number of staff but
it's there's not a significant issue
in terms of us being able to deliver
all of the requirements on us um when
all those posts posts are full
but i'm more than happy to discuss in
further detail with councillor channel
outside of the meeting
are you happy with that counselor
channel well i am i think
what i would suggest madam chairman um
like where we have lack of staff
resource or whatever the wording is
and if it is covered related then i
think that may have been
helpful to put that at the point where
it says lack of resources or due to
resources
if there was covered implications then
that might have been helpful
uh because remember members of the
public are reading this also
so that's where i'm coming from but yes
perhaps i will discuss outside of the
meeting because there's several and one
of them was tourism as well
i think we've now got the staff in place
but i think that was partly
um staff resources again madam chairman
thank you
thank you um i think i i would
personally like to be party to that
discussion if i may please
uh absolutely i have no problem of
course all right
thank you um anyone else berno wishes to
raise
yes we've got council swain and then
councillor head
okay councillor swain go ahead please
thank you chairman yes i have actually
five
five comments on this item in appendix
one
uh mostly for clarification or
information
um my page pages are as in the
printed papers so it page 64
and so on page 64 i i would like to
have perhaps not necessarily now but
outs separately
from some officer information about the
what is the year 6
transition template for junior schools
if i can move to page 66
place outcomes c and e
both refer to partnership working and
voluntary
input i wonder if we could have some
general indication of the
outside partners involved and the ex the
nature of the voluntary input into those
activities
page 68 on way i read it
the fly tipping performance seems to be
rather poor at least that's the way i
read the
um the graph um
page 69 and this is something that i
have um aired with matt lee and he's
given me an explanation
it is this peculiarity that if the major
house builders
are going slow this somehow turns into
a lack of
five-year housing land supply
but it is stated elsewhere that we do
have
five-year land supply my last point
concerns page 77 about job creation
i i would like to know what the meaning
is of the figure of 21 000
that is shown for um 18 and 19.
thank you thank you very much council
swain i'm not sure
if all your questions could be answered
at this meeting
but they will have been noted so i'm
sure that you will get a response
if we don't have the right offices
present at this meeting
are there any officers that wish to
speak on any of those points
chairman i if i may help just with
regard to the the fly tipping
um very much thank you yeah very much a
variable picture
um there are obviously a number of fly
tips um some of them are on public lands
some other on private land and perhaps
private land isn't reflected in the
figures so it perhaps doesn't give a
true figure
of uh the scale of perhaps the potential
we certainly monitor it and track it
on a regular basis we are beginning to
see an upturn in flight tipping
um there are a number of reasons that
that could be occurring um
obviously at the moment within the
district we've only got one of the um
household recycling centres open
in malden and not in in the dengue in
the birmingham crouch but we understand
the county council are working to reopen
uh that now that social distancing rules
have been relaxed
um so we're hoping that we see that open
and obviously that helping with fly
tipping so
although i can't account for every uh
kind of instance in terms of
detail why but i can say we are
monitoring our contractor monitors
and obviously working with us to uh try
and resolve that problem
thank you very much mr holmes are there
any other officers that could answer any
of the other points that council swain
has raised please
yes chairman i'm i'm happy to answer the
the last two points that um
councillor swain raised um the first
being
around the strategic site development
and the five-year housing land supply
councillor swine is correct we do have a
five-year housing land supply
um we we undertake um monitoring work
and um establish that
annually and provide returns on that
and publish that figure so we do have a
five-year house in land supply
we also passed the housing delivery test
which is a government
check on the the progress with with
delivery of housing
um according to the ldp so we're well on
track
um with both of those um despite the
the um the the information as
presented here um
obviously the the current covid um
downturn and the the slowdown of work on
site
may have a national impact on that and
there are national discussions going on
around how that
may affect the way that five-year
housing land supplies are reviewed
um in the coming year but currently yes
we have a five-year house in land supply
and yes we were
one of the councils that passed the
housing delivery test
sorry that the next one was oh it was
the 21 000 jobs
wasn't it um that relates to the life
of the local development plan that that
figure
so the the progress is related in
terms of working towards that figure
it's not broken down into
individual years it's a figure for the
life of the ldp
so any progress um shows progress
towards that overall target
thank you
wayne i know there were a couple of
other points
um sorry is there another member
officer that wishes to speak uh yeah so
um
cheryl i was just going to say that the
other questions that you've asked for
more detail around i can always take
those back offline and come back
with the information i think if you
would do that that would be helpful
and if you could copy your response to
me as well please thank you
well man are you happy with that
councilor swain yes fine thank you
madam chairman sorry now just come in
if there's going to be an offline
response could it be circulated to all
committee members
yes we can do that yes
what members require yes of course
um okay so any other
members that wish to speak bernard yes
ma german
and councillor heard and could we ask
members not to use the
raising of the hand function because we
don't have that facility for all at the
moment
to use to remind everybody to use the
chat feed
but it's counselor hired next thank you
thank you chairman uh i i just want to
talk about um
staff turnover can we assured can we be
assured that we're not
losing our local expertise
and reskilling new staff do we have any
way to
indicate to members where we stand
to reassure continuity of service
or performance please
thank you have we got an officer that
would
comment on that please
yes yes how happy to um
to comment on that um madam chairman
um traditionally molden has had a very
low turnover of stuff
obviously through the um transformation
that that changed to some degree as we
were
um looking at changing roles that were
going forward
um over the last six months to eight
months since since we went live
things have very much um
stabilized in in terms of that and we're
we've now got
much less uh turnover and
you know we're filling those those posts
up to full establishment
so we can look at those figures
specifically to look at what the annual
figure
is for for staff turnover and possibly
look at it
over the last eight months as well to
show how it's stabilized since
the end of the transformation and go
live there um and happy to
provide a bit more detail on that if we
do some analysis on it
thank you very much so mr johnson will
that be part of the
performance that that information will
come through
in performance reports or is it
something separate
it was something separate we as officers
we obviously monitor
um in in a lot of detail all of the
operations so i'll draw it out of that
and and share it with members and see if
there's any further analysis
needed and that will be to this
committee
yes thank you
um any other members wishing to speak
yes councilman's channel has a question
okay councillor stiltz then really
because council of china has already
raised something can i take councillor
stilts first please
thank you madam chairman can i ask mr
dobson that when he does the um
review of the staff turnover can we see
um anonymously
anonymously um the reason
the exit questionnaire for any staff
that has
just recently left um i take it we do do
an exit questionnaire for all-out
leavers
so that might be quite good to see
mainly
looking at why they are actually leaving
us
thank you councillors to us i will say
your volume is very low
sorry madam chairman okay
um mr johnson you wanted to comment on
that
um my understand we we obviously do
undertake um exit interviews my
understanding is that they're they're
confidential
i would have to check the status of any
data within those before making any
commitment to release those
i will ask the question thank you
council channel
thank you madam chairman um it's just
tying in really with that question
counselor heard asking about when staff
leave and also what mr dodson said and
what he's now going to be doing
can i just ask and bearing in mind
actually i i can speak
um firsthand on this because i was
involved somewhere where i was given
this information
i think sometimes what happens is some
of the stuff we may have lost may have
had a lot of the useful information
contained within their heads and not
necessarily written down and that
includes
processes and protocols will uh mr
dawson be covering how that might be
addressed to ensure that when we leave
you gonna lose long-standing staff good
staff who have a lot of knowledge in the
practices etc
and any knowledge that might be in their
heads that we make sure we capture that
before they go and what process might be
applied to ensure that happens so that
knowledge that's in the heads can be
transferred across
to other staff whether it be a manual or
anything i did ask some years ago and it
was going to be happening and i don't
think it has
about um a manual for planning bearing
in mind plan has changed pretty quickly
could we have couldn't there be a manual
just whereby you know
a protocol for each process so anyone
coming in could see it i was told that
was going to go
happen by head of planning service um
some
years ago actually i'm not sure that
ever came to fruition because again that
person left and maybe that not have
continued so i'm just asking about
containing that knowledge base that may
be going out and
if you lose all your knowledge at one
time you're starting from scratch
effectively
thank you councillor janna have we got
any
officers that wish to comment on that
yes mr holmes would like to
mr holmes please go ahead mr holmes
thank you chairman um yes obviously
regarding loss of
information and skills out of the
authority is a serious matter um i can
give a reassurance that obviously when a
member of staff does leave the council
there is a process where we actually go
through with them to actually get that
information and make sure that we we
understand that the processes that they
are responsible for
and able to um to take forward i think
obviously through transformation it's
helped a great deal because a lot of our
process is now well documented of course
there are always things that uh staff
actually do which is perhaps not as well
documented
and but we're in certainly a much better
position than we have been in the past
in terms of
fully documenting our processes and our
systems so just wanted to reassure that
our managers and team leaders
very much aware of knowledge lost from
the authority and and take the necessary
steps
okay thank you have we got any more
members that wish to speak bernard yes
we have counsellor nun
councillor nunn would you like to speak
now please
thank you very much chairman yes just
picking up on the points that
uh councillors have already made and the
responses from officers
regarding turnover um
any organization is going to have a
minimal turnover
and high levels of turnover and low
levels of turnover
can be good or bad things depending on
the circumstances and the context
so when we get this report and i do
really think the report needs to come to
all of us not to individual
members i'd like to see where that's
being benchmarked
in terms of other authorities i'd like
to know numbers
uh in terms of the staff leaving and
being appointed
and i'd like to see that by grade or by
tear
and i'd also like to see destinations
in terms of those that are leaving and i
can assure mr dobson
from my experience in hr that that is
not confidential information
it won't it won't identify individual
people
it just will give us numbers in terms of
the staff and will give us
categories of destination thank you very
much
okay thank you thank you councillor none
um well as
mr johnson said it it will there will be
a report coming back to this committee
on this
so thank you i know if we've got anyone
any other members
speakers okay members then we will go to
the recommendations there are
four little recommendations um
just briefly cover those uh review the
information
um assured that the review
has been managed effectively challenge
the performance
and question
on the um decisions and performance well
i think we've done all those
so if members are happy um
i would like a seconder to that
recommendation
those four little recommendations please
wait a second madam chairman
thank you councillor chana
uh berna have we got anyone
now from bdo present
we need to take we need to take yes we
do need to take a vote members are we
all happy to go
um rather than individually as a
uh
that's agreed then so berna have we got
miss donnelly now or anyone else from
bdo yes we've got miss donnelly she's
ready to present
thank you thank you then we will go back
then to item
six on the agenda which was internal
audit reports
progress follow-up recommendations and
network security
so again reminding members to go into
the chat function rather than using
um the hand because not everyone has got
the hand on their
machine so we must use the chat function
if you want to speak
and it try and keep your points clear
and succinct thank you
so mr donnelly are you happy to go ahead
and present the report please
yes i am thank you chair and i'll start
with page 21 of the meet and pak
and this just outlines the progress
since the last committee meeting
and there has been one audit finalized
so that is the network security report
which i will run through in a moment
and also the community safety report
which has been issued in draft
and in terms of other reports i also
present the follow-up recommendations
report
and in terms of the 2021 audit plan
obviously there has been some delays due
to staff capacity due to
um the corona virus so i've been working
with officers to
to just um kind of re re-look at the
plan
see if everything in there is still
relevant and when we can begin field
work
and we've now come up with a plan so
i'll bring that forward to the next
committee meeting
and for approval and but in the meantime
we'll be starting
the q2 audits that have been scheduled
and i'll just move along then to
the um sorry to the follow-up
recommendations report if there's no
other if there's no questions
on um the general progress
um do you want to go through the whole
thing and then we'll come back to
questions
oh okay um in terms of the
follow-up report and there's been some
good progress and there's been a lot of
recommendations
implemented regarding mit disaster
recovery
and procurement and contract management
and around disaster recovery we have
seen
that and disaster recovery plan has been
updated
and tested and so that closes off a lot
of the recommendations
and in terms of those that are over g
the first one of these is around the
fraud risk assessment
and i've been working with director of
resources this week to
come up with a plan to get this done as
soon as possible and i think we're now
at the stage where
and we'll be able to progress the work
over the summer i just need to get
and some dates on when we can start to
deliver some
um training to um the key staff that i
need to know about some
kind of fraud issues so procurement hr
and finance
and so at the next committee we'll be
able to
provide um a detailed plan of timings
when when the various kind of fraud work
will begin
and the other overdue recommendation is
around risk management um
and obviously the bass for an extension
to july to complete that just due to
staff capacity
and and getting the the risk and
kpis in place and time for this
committee
so that one remains overdue with a
request extend to july
and network security um network security
this was a moderate moderate report
since the time of um completion actually
all each of the recommendations have now
been implemented
but i'll just run through what we did so
this was looking at how secure the
council's controls were
in terms of i.t systems and security any
vulnerabilities that may have existed
and around infrastructure and the the
support and software
we identified a lot of good practice but
we had three and
three recommendations one was around the
it
password policy and data security
training and
complaints this this has now been done
and compliance will be monitored by hr
and we also noted that there's need for
cyber risk assessments to be undertaken
on a regular basis
and with all potential cyber risks and
mitigations documented
and any controls in place this has now
also been done and also we recommended
and that the council obtained
vulnerability scanning tool and which
has also been created this will improve
ongoing awareness of any system
weaknesses that can be enacted as soon
as they arise
so there's there was a couple of things
that need to be done which have actually
all now been implemented
that's everything very much for that
thank you
so have we got much
any members that wish to con you who
actually
members if you've got a question on any
of those three you can take them all
together
you might have a question on each one or
or just one but we'll
take whatever questions so we have
counselors swaying fast
okay thank you berna councillor swain
um yes i have had three quick questions
on the
appendix
appendix one i think on page 21 and one
on appendix 2 page 31.
on page 21 can you clarify please
what does an audit of community safety
cover
as far as mdc is concerned um
the flood risk management um
state is that the groundwork has been
done
yeah i can't recall from what you just
said whether
you've got any sort of dead deadline
when you might
have a report to come to council and the
third one is the timetable for the
audit of the corporate planning and
corporate plan and priorities
my fourth one on the page 31 is
and it really applies elsewhere i think
and that is the threshold of 25 000
pounds for
um what should we say more intensive and
cooperative um discussion of procurement
bids
as auditors are you happy that 25 000
is um not too high
a figure or do you think it should be
lower
before to trigger wider discussion of
any procurement
business thank you
thank you cancer swing mr donnelly would
you like to comment on that please yes
i'll start with um community cfd so this
was
in terms of a reference per agreed with
officers this was looking at
um how the the council works with
um the kind of the all the different
um stakeholders so place and
and other groups and i would need to
go back and look at the terms of
reference exactly to see what all was
included
in in the audit
um which i can i can i can send through
the terms of reference if that would be
useful offline i just don't have the
detail right now
okay um
in terms of the flooding risk management
the
field of work has been completed but we
are awaiting some
final um information from um
officers to try and get the report um
issued and draft
and i think there's some delays due to
the key member of staff
and have not had the capacity to provide
some information just obviously just due
to
coronavirus and but the field work has
been completed overall and we
expect to be issuing a draft report in
the next two weeks i would imagine
and in terms of the
what was the question around corporate
plan and priority and do you have a
timetable for work on that
um so that one we had initially agreed
um
a mid july started but because um
of just the delays with um getting some
of the work started we
have had come up with um a revised
internal audit plan
which i'm hoping to bring to the next
committee and that's something i've been
working with
officers this week on and um there
maybe it is decision to defer that audit
depend
on audit days and resources because
we're obviously adding some
work around the counter fraud plan and
into the days for this year
and there was another question wasn't
there cancer point was about whether you
considered the 25
000 pound threshold high too high
for triggering um which we said wider
discussion of any procurement business
um sorry one second
i mean i i guess it's you know in line
with
the you know the procurement regulations
that the council
works towards and obviously there are
there are a number of controls in place
that the procurement team would be
involved in
in some of the um contracts and tenders
lower than
that value you find
madam chairman that's possibly a
question that i
should raise in a different um a
different forum is it
well regarding yes it's part of our
procurement process so yes it's not some
i mean we can
think about it elsewhere but not here
okay
thank you um so mr donnelly on the first
question then you've got to come back on
that so
could you come back um to all the
committee met well to me and then i'll
circulate it to all committee members
yeah thank you
are you happy mr cancer swain yes thank
you
thank you berna have we got any one
other member who wishes to speak on this
yes you've got cancer jarvis then
councillor durham and finally
council mrs chana okay councillor jarvis
thanks very much chairman i mean my
question was
on um it's on page
35 of the report uh
emma donnelly has commented on it
already this is the fraud
fraud risk assessment i know the
director of resources is going to
commission external resource
and amadona has commented obviously that
she's that she's currently having
uh discussions about uh getting on with
this
i'm conscious that it is uh it is
outstanding from quite a while back
it is should be quite a high priority
and i just wondered if we might ask the
director of resources to
confirm that uh that basically we're
going to get on with that job
i don't want to be here at the end of
the year still discussing
that we're going to get on with it soon
i'd like to know that it's going to be
done
over the next few months thank you
thank you
as the director of resources
yes absolutely thank you madam chairman
just wait just waiting for you you've
got a prompt
uh yes happy to confirm i appreciate um
i've only been here less than two months
but you've been waiting for this for far
longer
um so he's a top priority uh i've said
we've already formed a action plan
within within this time period
and we're looking to implement that uh
asap uh
preferably so uh yeah very much getting
on with it and we've got a plan and
we're going to implement it
so yeah i have to report that thank you
thank you so much
it's good listening um so we've got
councillor durham
councillor dharam you have a question i
do chairman
thank you very much indeed chairman uh
um
have you got me yes yes yes um thank you
thank you very much uh the question i
would like to ask is actually about what
things are happening now
uh the government's coveted financial
support measures
um obviously that the district council
is
uh has been um administering
we've had it reported at essex that
there has
clearly been a lot of fraud and
obviously when we have
uh things like these financial packages
um the fraud potential is considerable
um but it has been reported that the
there has been
regrettably quite a lot of fraud and i
would like to know
uh what measures the authority is taking
um
to prevent this from occurring please
thank you uh director of resources
mr would you want to comment on that one
yes thank you
yes so the council has uh fraud
procedures uh
in place as well um as and also has
instructions for individual departments
as well uh as part of the arrangements
we're also strengthening those we've had
training
as well for staff and i believe as the
uh fraud audit
recently took place it wasn't just this
one recommendation that still
outstanding there were a number which
have been implemented so there are a
number of good practices that have now
been
implemented and put in place uh one of
the areas as well is
around particularly around procurement
as you can imagine
certainly you get a lot of people trying
to change uh
bank details and suppliers in that way
so it's very much something that
we're alive to we've got processes and
procedures around that
as well to come in place so it's looking
at those high risk areas
so we've got a lot of good work that's
been done already as part of the audit
and we're going to continue with that
action plan going forward as well so
it's very much
on the radar thank you very much for
that
chairman just come back yeah sure well
i was specifically asking ab about the
the covid grants etc
uh that uh have actually been turned
around extremely quickly by the
authority
uh in me and i've certainly had a lot of
communication congratulating the
authority only
but i'm just wondering whether the
alacrity of of giving out these grants
has been to the detriment
of preventing fraudulent requests please
apologize councillor uh regards that as
well
um that's something that we've put in
place
um the team as you know there's been a
very push to get the grants out quickly
and what we feel that the council has
done is balance that with the need for
appropriate checks
and reasonable checks as well so we felt
that we've done that in a very
sensible manner and checks are being
carried out and we've requested
information
so there are these processes in place
for these grants as well
and so we're satisfied that we've done
the reasonable checks that are required
there also be some follow-up work that's
currently being undertaken
led by central government and other
bodies in response to the fraud so we're
taking part in those national
fraud initiatives as well so there's
some follow-up work to be done so the
first chance we've done our response
checks we've paid the grants but we're
also going to do
further work as well as part of the
national drive to capture fraud and
investigate fraud and follow up
on any of those things so we feel we've
we've done what's required
around that and we'll continue to do so
thank you very much indeed that's that's
well answered and again congratulations
for turning them around so quickly thank
you
thank you very much uh counselor channel
believe you had a
question um thank you um
gosh it's gone now right i'll do it from
memory again uh madam chairman thank you
i'm homing in actually on uh councillor
jarvis's
question um it seems really um centering
on that that's because it is a high
priority level and it is about the fraud
risk assessment
and heard the director of resources
state now that we have got
an action plan and it's impossible with
that
and we need to make sure we uh implement
that as soon as possible
and the report itself on current
progress says we about the outline
action plan agreed by the end of june
with delivery as soon as practical are
just really seeking some clarification
on that madam chairman
you know we're hearing as soon as
possible and as soon as practical
an action plan to my knowledge would
have several elements to it and each of
those elements of action
should have a timeline and therefore um
whenever we say delivery as soon as
practical i'd really like to have an
indication
of sort of some flow of this or timeline
when we think
this would come in because it could go
if
if these actions aren't signed off quick
enough or implemented quick enough
could go on as councillor jarvis
indicated for some considerable period
of time
could we be given an indication of when
all these actions are meant to be
concluded
are some of them long term with checks
going on in between
i'm not quite it's just deliberately as
soon as practical what will influence
that practical
delivery you know so we can have a short
term uh where it's implemented
or we could find ourselves going into a
region of where we're going into another
financial year after this even okay
thank you mr leslie
thank you yes i've very much pushed into
an open door i agree it's a priority and
i want to get on with it as soon as
possible so
we're aligned in terms of our thinking
there what we've got
in terms of the time the report comes to
you and the time it's written
is obviously a bit of a delay so what
that wording does is not to commit to
something we haven't agreed at the time
of writing
but at the same time you're asking a
very sensible question when we're
getting on with it
so as um as donnelly has indicated we've
had those discussions
have taken place and we are looking at a
follow-up meeting with one of their
fraud leads to get on with this
with a start date in in next month as
well
and once we have those initial
discussions we'll be able to film out
some dates
uh for the whole action plan going
forward so what i don't want to do is
present you with some dates that we
haven't agreed
uh and there will be false information
for you so what we're doing now
is looking at how we tackle it and stay
doing that and we're going to start the
work
i have to report back um how we're going
with that and actually what dates we're
looking
to achieve so it's very much question
getting on with soon possible we're
getting on with it in july
and we're going to report back to you
with the plan so we are
trying to get on with this as soon as we
can
thank you for that mr leslie well we do
have a meeting at the end of july so
perhaps we could
have an update then with dates and
progress that would be good
thank you um
sorry mr leslie should you want to come
back no um
berna have we got any other members that
wish to speak yes chairman we've got
councillor stamp
okay councillor stamp thank you chairman
um mr leslie wasn't around when
uh we was at a previous meeting when it
was identified an area
of weakness or an area of development
when the
previous audits were carried out and one
of the areas i was really concerned with
was councillors expenses now it was
identified that
there wasn't the sufficient checks and
balances
could mr lesner assure me or reassure me
that that area has been looked into
now uh that petrol receipts are being
given and destinations and mileages are
being checked
thank you chairman thank you councillor
stan
mr leslie sorry we're putting you on the
spot a bit here no no no
it's quite a ride thank you i quite
understand there was a lot of
um a lot of activity around this area
in in the past uh i believe now that
there is guidance
up on the site where you do fill in your
returns i've seen it and i've seen the
form you use
to complete the returns as well in terms
of
the fuel receipts they are no longer
they're not required
in terms of the issue i don't believe
this was as a point raised uh
in a report uh previously was about
recording
the start and end destination and um
from recollection
that has been tackled in the form as
well where you enter the the postcodes
i believe to start and finish time so i
believe those points have been
uh picked up and addressed now
thank you mr leslie but i i know that i
have not received
anything to advise me of this new form
no i'm not sure any other members have
so
um if there is a new form we need to
know obviously at the moment we're not
using
petrol to get to uh the office but um
you know we haven't seen this new form
or been advised of any new processes as
far as i know
okay i will pick up with the team and
just see what's going
uh in the past with large communication
and clearly if i'm being told that
you're not up to speed with it then
communications need to go out and so we
get that looked at yeah
thank you thank you chairman for
allowing that because i i actually don't
claim so i don't deal with anything like
that but it did concern me that that was
highlighted as a public meeting
and we need to be shown to be doing what
we're looking after public money
in all areas thank you yes thank you
very much councillor stamp for raising
that
um any other members berna yes
councillor nunn
that's a nun
i'm sorry sorry truman my microphone was
off yes so a follow up for mr leslie
um i i continue to be confused
why this council believes that they
should not ask for petrol receipts
surely if it's an issue with vat
uh that that's one one aspect if it's an
issue of
taxable benefit um with
individual members and officers
having this taken into account with
their
tax coding surely there needs to be an
audit trail
whereby the revenue can be assured that
the
payments that are made equate to excess
mileage
and that the expenditure has been
undertaken
okay thank you councillor none but i
think as uh
mr leslie said um
you know we as members haven't really
been told that we don't need petrol
receipts we always used to
have to submit petrol receipts i don't
know who's made the decision
um to not have petrol receipts now so
i think we need to wait for some advice
from
someone i do appreciate i do appreciate
that trevor but mr leslie has made a
specific statement which is petrol
receipts are not required
and i'm intrigued to know why okay
thank you council done mr leslie do you
want to come back on that do you know
the answer
yes happy to come back thank you madam
chairman
yep so this relates to uh
efficiencies it doesn't relate to
taxable benefits or anything like that
it's purely a look at efficiencies
and the work was undertaken it was
deemed that the administration
uh cost of uh doing this far
outweighed uh the financial benefit of
doing that so there's purely a look at
that and saying actually
this is a very labor time intensive
process for very little
financial benefit and therefore the
costs outweighed the benefit of having
this procedure
in place oh my god
thank you mr leslie i don't think
members
that that we know about that but um
yes okay well we'll move on is there um
any other member who is just a speed
burner uh council mr channel would just
like to come back on the issue of the
form
the expenses thank you very much
well i i did know about no v80 receipts
and in fact
i got told about that when we had the
first issue of the members um expenses
when there was the hiccup
and i attended a meeting i was told i
did question about that and
uh what mr leslie has just said is the
message i got
i have seen the new form madam chairman
uh during code i went to do my march
mileage and i received it
um and because i also queried the policy
i got the policy sent as well i made
some representation on the policy
because it was slightly different to
what i've been told in a meeting
um and i was told that would be amended
anyway i did utilize the form
and putting the postcode in however i
was only able to go so far
before things happened it didn't seem to
work so i did manage to submit it and i
spoke to david wall who's a very good
officer
he sent me another form to say using
future but he said i was quite right
there was a hiccup with the form
so i'm hoping that that now has been
sorted and the form we use that all
members will be using the one that does
work
um because there was a certain point
when you filled in you you found
yourself
well i won't explain it all now but all
i can say is i'm aware of the form as
well
and there is a policy as well um of
members
and i think that was signed off um when
i was querying something it was the days
of tina stankly
um she said about a policy having to be
signed off somewhere i think so
i believe that has happened and i've
seen a copy of it
thank you councillor chana well i think
mr leslie we just need some
clarification on that
um and it probably needs to go to all
members i wasn't aware of a
new policy but then this could have come
through the kovit 19 interim measures
group i guess
um so we await your advice on that one
mr leslie
um any other members berna uh councillor
stilts
sorry and councillor herd and councillor
stills
okay councillor stilts
thank you madam chairman um question for
mr leslie
when we had the last audit report i did
actually query um there was a thing on
there that said
that out of 10 um company credit cards
that were
um looked at there was
anomalies where they hadn't actually
been signed off to say that they were
actually used
for company business can mr leslie
assured me
that that has now been rectified
thank you mr leslie could you just
confirm that
i'll look into that and get back but if
it was raised at the time then i'm
confident it would have been but let me
look into that and get back to the group
just to see exactly what the issue was
the wording and what's been put in place
okay thank you thank you on that uh
councillor heard
um thank you matt thank you madam
chairman i i have to say
uh i i'm really very very surprised
that we're not doing any of these checks
about mileage receipts
um certainly in my time as as a
councillor
um i've never claimed any mileage and i
never intend to
but i do think that there should be some
checks
uh and there is an opportunity for this
council to claim back the vat
surely and i really can't see why it
isn't viable
and i'm very very surprised that we're
not looking at that
thank you thank you council hud um well
i think
um mr leslie's report on this to us will
clarify those points um there is a
policy now apparently agreed so
we need to look at that and decide um if
we want to look at this any further
um so um any other members fernan
no no chairman um right well i
i personally as we've got someone from
it would like to ask for an
update on the um report on network
security where there is a section for
high
um which did concern me um it does
mention
um going back to january discussions
and i just wanted to ask for
some guidance on whether the
recommendations have been put in place
on that one
we still got mr hulley here uh yes
chairman and
he can answer that question thank you
just i'm using hello chairman
um yes uh so there was one high item
when it came to the
security side of our network i'm just
putting it up in front of me now to make
sure i've got it
to hand
scroll down here
[Music]
yes so the high item was specifically
around
um i.t training in this case so a budget
being provisioned to allow for
um training of our staff on password
security and data security
um thankfully we actually had a system
in place which is known as e-learning
um we have now utilized that with the
ict policies uh there's three in total
um to essentially train our staff on
both password
length password security and best
practices
as well as confirming that uh when they
access or use data
that could that access is controlled um
so that's now being implemented uh
staff are actively being trained using
this e-learning platform
and that's now being monitored by hr as
well
okay that's very good thank you so much
for that
um okay bernard so we have no more
members on the item
no that's right thank you okay so we're
going now members to the recommendations
which are three little
recommendations um
to approve the appendix one two and
three
um on the internal audit reports um
so do i have a seconder to those
recommendations please would you put
your
video and microphone on if you want a
second
yes counselor damn is indicating he's
secondary
okay it are all members happy with that
with those recommendations agree agreed
agreed agreed thank you very much
okay then we go on to um agenda item
eight which is the quarterly
review of corporate risk um
so again reminding you to use the chat
function i think most of you are doing
that now so that's great
um so i go to um cheryl hughes
um to present this report please
thank you chairman and i'm just going to
share my screen again to show you the
report
and hopefully that should now be live
okay so this is the quarter full report
of
risk and it's provided for member review
it's worth noting that the corporate
leadership team have been reviewing and
keeping a close eye on the risk register
on a weekly basis since the start of the
coveted emergency measures
the report provided shows direction of
travel between quarter three when
this was last reported to pga and then
quarter four
so overall there are three risks that
have seen a decrease in score
so first i'll take you to um
risk number 29 which is um
failure to deliver services as a result
of covid19
and then we've got risk 22 which is on
page six
so that's contracts not managed or owned
and not providing value for money
and risk 20. so that's the
failure to have a disaster recovery and
business continuity plan
and there were also new additions to the
risk register for this
period so we've got risk 29
which was new and it's also seen a
decrease
in that time where it's been reviewed so
frequently
but that's the failure to deliver
services as a result of covid19
and risk 28 um
which was the finance audit debtors
creditors and expenses around a
poor audit outcome so this was a raise
raised for inclusion as it temporarily
met the corporate threshold
but it has since been mitigated and
recommended for closure
and because the finance audit actions
are now in place
so this information is provided to um
give members an approach to review
risk management and challenge whereas
there's concern on corporate delivery
um and i think that covers everything
so oh sorry uh three risks where we've
seen an
increase in score as well so just to
take you to those
um so we've got risk nine which is about
a coordinated approach to inward
investment and business rate growth
um risk 15 which is failure to plan and
deliver
balanced budgets and risk two
which is about failure to target
services and influence
partners around the vulnerable
population
all three of those have seen an increase
in risk score due to the impact of
covid19
so that's a summary of what's gone on in
that the reporting quarter
thank you thank you very much um
cheryl for that um just to remind
members that this
risk register is owned by the clt
so we comment on what we consider
um are the are these risk scores
not the content of the risk itself
um so berna have we got members that
wish to speak on this
yes we've got council swain councillor
heard
and counselor jarvis councillor sweden
councillors wayne thank you
madam chairman a couple of uh
one question firstly on that um
um i would like to know who has
responsibility
for that that is the um
coordinated um economic strategy
as i remember the wording and as a
general point
um i
questioned the weighting overall that
was given
if you look at the
the two sets of numbers the likelihood
and the impact
um impact very
little between levels three and four
and occasionally five whereas likelihood
varies from one to five so in fact the
final score is very much biased by the
estimation of likelihood
rather than impact um this is
a sort of feature of the psychology i
suppose of how people assess
the weightings but to my mind the
overall result
is that the um overall risk
factor doesn't really take sufficient
account of
how important the particular risks are
it can't be simply reduced to one number
multiplied by another
okay thank you well this has been
revised from what we had
originally um and since miss cheryl
hughes has been with us
um this has been changed this um
way of doing it so cheryl would you like
to explain a bit more about the
how it works so the risk rating score on
a five by five scale is actually
um the scale is actually shown at the
start of the appendix as well so
to show what the criteria are for scores
one to five
for likelihood and impact um and the
reason that we've moved to a 5x5 scale
is that standard industry practice
and it actually came out of an internal
risk audit that bdo did
that actually we we were previously
working on a 4x4 scale
and that wasn't best practice which is
why we've moved to the 5x5 scale and the
scores have been revised
thank you councillor swain i think you
raised a particular
point somewhere on this um yes
should we say the ownership if that's
the current expression of
our nine the um
what page is that on it's the first it's
just top of the list
oh failure to have a coordinated
approach
to supporting inward investment and
maximizing rate growth
and your query is who's responsible for
that or who
who has ownership of that chairman mr
dodson is coming in
sorry runner sorry
mr dodson is is excited to address that
thank you all right thank you mr johnson
thank you chairman
um yes ownership for that sits within my
directorate
um and you know in answering that i
would like to address the the five and
the five
um score on that at the same time um
you know it hasn't been that high it is
purely a reflection of covid
you know that the impact of anything we
do currently
um at a micro level as
we work in in economic terms is
outweighed by the macro effects of the
the covid um emergency so the impact on
the world economy
and the national economy outweighs the
what we can do
to coordinate to deliver that so so
that's why we've put it up to five
and five because basically we're it's
not within
our gift or our control at the moment
the issues that we're dealing with
all right thank you does that explain
councillor swain
um in a sense yes but
um it brings out my point that it's
given this very high rating
and yet it is an area which is not
really um
much under the um influence of
district council
if if i could come back again
that that's absolutely correct that it
you know it's not within our control
but it is a risk to us it's a risk to us
in terms of
our targets around job creation it's a
risk to us around
our business rate income so it has a
huge impact
on us and it's absolutely right that we
put it on there as a risk
even though it's not necessarily one
that we can
at the current time control because of
those external factors which outweigh
any internal factors
thank you but at any time we have
very little influence over it
thank you okay all right thank you
councillors waiting for that uh council
heard
um thank you my question actually was
why are the numbers not in order but i
see that they've been sorted
in the overall risk rating so obviously
the overall risk
is the highest and and then that
gradually decreases
um if it's if it's an industry standard
fair enough it can't be changed but i
just think that uh
it would be better with a red amber
green if it's rising it's red
if it's unchanged it's amber and if it
lowers it's green it's just
very easy to see which state way that is
as far as things like
risk nine failure to have the
coordinated approach
as councillor swain has said it's not
something that we would necessarily have
control over
but then that can be shown to be
mitigated in the commentary
and and i think that should although it
says focus now on applying
government-based
business support and i just think it's
an easier way of
indicating whether they've gone up
staying where they are or gone down
um but if it's the industry standard
but if there are if there are room for
improvements that's just a uh
a constructive criticism thank you
all right thank you councillor i take
your point about the traffic light thing
because we did have that before
um and it was in a way easier to see but
i
but this this way we've got the overall
risk highest first
and then as it goes lower so i think
it's fair enough
as it is so councillor jarvis
my question is just on governance
could i ask where
in the risk register it identifies
ineffective governance as a risk
and my sort of secondary question would
be
but in view of the activity at the
moment with regards to
governance working parties and internal
audits
on corporate governance when can
the performance governance and audit
committee
expect a substantive report uh on
governance
and could could we have that at the next
meeting please
mr johnson do you want to comment on
that one
yes yes thank you um chairman um
i i'm happy to discuss that with um
council jobs i'm not clear exactly what
what
he's asking for within that report
um obviously there's a corporate
governance working group
are currently doing some work in light
of the
um remote committees and the move to
those and how that works
post um october
and how that will be agreed at the the
statutory annual council
in september um but i wasn't
entirely sure which piece of work he he
wanted a report on
um to come to the committee next time is
that that will go to council that report
council jarvis yes i'm just uh
i think my first question was where does
ineffective
governance appear in the risk register
um if it's in there i can't see it
if it's not there should it be that
perhaps that's a question for
um cheryl and the second part was
regarding the report
i think you know if we are if we are the
performance in governance audit
it just seems to me that uh we don't be
derelict in our duties
um i think a report telling me that
governance is all okay
would be fine but if it's not i'd quite
like to see
a substantial report telling me perhaps
commenting on
areas that are under review or
recommendations
i'm just puzzled that obviously we are
pga
and yet we don't seem to get any any
reports on government so that's really
my point
mr dodson do you want to comment on that
yes thank you chairman i mean i mean
governance is something that there isn't
fluid um all of the time so so it's not
something that
um there are reports that that would
come through
through monthly um in that way
um if as a one-off report the the um
council of jarvis would like us to to
review
um the governance i mean that would
normally be an audit function um
i'll could i take it away and and
give it some thought as to to what we
might might present and i'll discuss
with councillor jarvis
um and due chairman um to look at what
we might do around that piece of work
yes thank you thank you chairman so i
don't think i got an answer to the first
part
is it in the risk register in effective
governance
mr johnson um we i
i can't tell you every single risk that
we have in there we do have risks
um um that cover from a
um operational level through to the
corporate risk register which is seen
which is those which are
the higher risks um it's not one
that has been flanked up as a major risk
um because the the the obviously the
risk levels would would be low but
i'll i'll check on where we are with
that
and report back to um councillor
okay thank mr thompson could i just ask
who is the chief risk officer of the
council
risk sits within my directorate i am the
risk manager
thank you very much thank you
council jarvis and mr dodson anyone else
berna any other member
wishes to speak yes councillor herd
would like to ask a supplementary
question
okay counselor
yeah thank you chairman um i think that
only a week or so ago
i and i know other members
were actually interviewed by internal
audit
on governance when will we see that
result
please
thank you i think that's probably a
question for
mrs miss donnelly i don't know whether
she's still with us
um oh sorry
hi yes and the field work for that's now
being completed
and um i would just need to confirm the
dates
um for the next when the papers are due
next they'll either be
coming to the next um mini meeting or
the one after
but i should be able to let you know
next week
so the next one is the 30th of july are
we likely to have it for that or not
and probably not the time it goes
through the assurance process
if the papers are due and two weeks
before that so it'll be the one after
that then
okay thank you thank you
any other members benner no chairman
um i'm aware members that no one's
really
challenged any of the uh scores
um but we're happy with those sorry
chairman councillor
swain has put a comment in governance
and overview and scrutiny i wasn't aware
it was a question
um governance and overview and scrutiny
council swain would apparently like to
ask a question on that
okay council swain yes thank you madam
chairman
um clearly with performance um we have
all this information because you can
have
a whole host of indicators of
performance
it's difficult to envisage indicators of
governance
but governance reporting on the
governance of the council
is a responsibility of the overview and
scrutiny committee
and they should they should report on
the
uh governance of the council as part of
their annual report
thank you councillor swain i think we
are looking at this
um in corporate governance at the moment
anyway so that will
a report will come back no doubt based
on that and
the audit report on corporate governance
um so members we uh move to the
recommendations unless anyone else
wants to challenge any risk scoring
which we haven't done we've gone through
the other recommendations
we've looked at how it's managed
effectively
commented but we haven't really
challenged any risk scoring but i mean
if
all members are happy then i will move
those four little recommendations if
someone
would second would they put their video
and um
on mute please yes counselor diamonds
indicated she's second in
the that's the don't okay thank you
recommended so
members are is everyone happy to agree
all those four little recommendations
okay great yes thank you thank you thank
you
thank you all um so we move on to
um agenda item nine
which is corporate health and safety
um i don't think i need to tell you
about the chat function i think we've
got that
now um so it's mr richard holmes who
will present this report please thank
you chairman members
this is the corporate health and safety
update from january the 1st
uh to the 31st of march during that
period there were five
accidents reported you'll see those at
3.1 on the report
one member of staff involved at an
outside activity
um some within the council officers
themselves and one member of the public
who uh
slipped and fell within the council
chamber itself
during the same period there are four
instances of unacceptable behavior
report of the quarter
um two incidents and two referrals some
other agencies and one muslim police
someone from the debaca uh department of
work and pensions
um you'll find it uh the appendix one
the health and safety
action plan for 1920 there has been some
delay in that plan obviously for uh
issues around kobit 19
and some of the um activities within
that plan itself
were more based around the office
occupation which of course were not at
the moment
i'd like to just draw your attention to
3.4 of the report and there was a visit
from the health and safety executive
regarding the operations within our
promenade depot this
was regarding how we segregated staff
from traffic movements
there are vehicle garages and storages
office retractors and vehicles that
maneuver
and there are a number of
recommendations that the health and
safety executive
made to the council and we've now
implemented all those um
and we understand that the case is now
closed
we was uh sorry it was technically at
fault so they've charged a fee
for the intervention which covers their
costs um
that's probably all i need to say on the
report chairman but happy to take any
questions
thank you thank you mr holmes um
members yes councillor chandler and
counselor nun would like to ask a
question
okay counselor
thank you madam chairman um yes on the
on the report
um well actually mr holmes has touched
on it the report that appendix one did
refer
to uh vibrate i'm going to look at the
one it's got vibration
and then it moves on and it's the and it
says about appendix one it's the first
one
and it does say and it refers to what mr
holmes just said um
about um something being material breach
in the law was found in relation to
workplace transport and i think you've
mentioned that to do with staff and
movements
but it does say see appendix 2 for
details
so when i go to appendix 2 for details
the only thing i can see is
prior to be given to the parks team due
to the high level of risk and outdated
procedures
if necessary contracting external
assistance to complete the task
i'm not quite clear what action has been
put in place to overcome
that breach uh which the wording in this
report says
um reach of the law um to overcome
and so we do comply with the law i'd
perhaps be grateful a bit of detail
around that because it sounds
quite serious um yes i absolutely can do
that um yes it
is serious because obviously it is a
concern for the health and safety of our
staff
um but fairly straightforward to resolve
so it's because of the layout of the
depot itself we've got an office and
greenhouse that runs alongside a roadway
and also we have tractor store buildings
um and often the vehicles are
maneuvering
and there was no segregation between the
footpath and the
the lane where the vehicles could be
turning so a health and safety executive
gave us some guidance in terms of how
they would thought the layout of the
yard should be changed and it was quite
straightforward
and we're putting a number of white and
yellow lines effectively
and some barriers that allow the staff
to walk along the pathway
um whilst vehicles are maneuvering and
that is to protect them
so it wasn't significant it certainly
wouldn't underplay the risks because
obviously vehicles and reversing and
and staff um obviously need to be kept
separated and but it's fairly
straightforward
and i say we undertook that work uh
quickly following the guidance
and the inspector came back and has
signed off as all completed
thank you mr holmes um is that are you
happy with that answer counselor jana
i am regarding appendix 2 though it does
seem to imply there's other outdated
procedures
in the parks but that's why they're high
priority and it seems to be that that
won't be the only issue that we need to
look at regarding health and safety
uh yes chairman i can and i can answer
that as well um
i think i triggered a review of our
health and safety simply because of the
the changes that the council had
undertaken during transformation
a number of different staff operations
had moved so i requested that we did a
review of our health and safety
procedures
and that includes all of our safe
working practices and all of our manuals
and yes we brought in some external
consultancy to give us
an overall view of that and gave us some
recommendations for change
and the staff have been working through
that so part of the process is to put in
a constant review
and we've also looked at training for
the staff to make sure that we're all
certificated
and they work at height they operate
machinery and so all of those things to
make sure that we've got robust
procedures in place
um risk assessments up to date safe
working practices are up to date
it's an ongoing piece of work it's
something we should never really stop um
cyclical work but obviously there is a
priority around making sure any
recommendations that come out of that
review
we would action as soon as possible
thank you mr holm
thank you mr holmes but did you say
there was someone else i can't remember
yes and councillor schemes thank you
chairman
okay councillor none thank you chair
um thank you mr holmes for your report
you mentioned
four instances of unacceptable behaviour
um
now i appreciate that uh some of these
people might not be our staff they might
be
subcontracted but i was saddened to read
in the media about
the collectors of recycling and refuse
being abused by certain
residents and i wondered if you could
comment on that in terms of volume and
issues
certainly um first i'd like to to uh
make it clear that the
unacceptable behavior was from
unfortunately from the public to our
staff
or to our partners yes absolutely they
are they are members of public who visit
the offices and um
their behaviour is simply not acceptable
to to us um
with regard to uh the refugee security
crews unfortunately there have been
a number of occurrences where um there
has been verbal abuse
um in one case a physical shelf to one
of the refuse operators
um and that clearly again that is not
acceptable um
one of them i think was reported to the
police um
and in a couple of occasions we've
actually suspended
the uh collection of the waste from that
particular household because of the
behaviour
of the residents um it's very sad um
obviously the reference queues are
working as hard as they can they've
worked
constantly through kovid whilst a lot of
us have been locked down they've been
out there doing the work as best they
can
um unfortunately some people's tolerance
uh is not as high
um and but obviously the important point
is that we won't accept
any of our staff or our contractors um
having verbal or physical abuse
and we will take action so that that was
the background to that
thank you very much thank you mr holmes
um councillor schemes was it um yes
cancer skins and then cancer stamp
chairman
thank you okay cancel the skeins oh yes
a couple of questions if i may
uh the uh accidents they're probably
nothing to worry about i hope but the
first question is
is there any likelihood that anybody
might take legal action and connection
to them
which obviously would be a further risk
and secondly
could we know what the fee was that the
hsc charge for their intervention
um i will come back with an exact figure
and i can circulate that i think it was
in the low hundreds but i just need to
to check that and it is on a time-based
um uh method so it's it's not a fine
it's a effectively a charge for fee so i
will uh update members on the actual
figure itself and but
uh unlike a a prosecution where they
find this is a
a fee but i will i'll give a figure and
with regard to the
um accidents um they were all minor of
minor in nature um obviously if there is
a claim against the council then that is
dealt with through our insurers i'm not
aware of any claim that's been put in as
a result of that quarter
any accidents thank you very much
cancer stamp uh yes can i ask please mr
holmes
if you know when you've just carried out
all your risk assessments most probably
under health and safety in kerbin 19
uh obviously we've done the same in burn
as most probably other parish councils
have done
are we allowed to have a copy for
anything say for the toilets or the part
that you've carried out
can we have them at our level please
because we've just done a big one and on
ours i've just put
that you are responsible for it but i
know that you'll have done a risk
assessment so can i have that
information or can we have that
back up anyway we get our level please i
think that would be really helpful
yeah and there's a couple of things
there i think the works we've done
absolutely under covid
we can share because there's a
government toolkit where you do an
assessment of your
high street and the size around the high
street number of pedestrians and that is
effectively a risk assessment
i'm happy to get that shared and as for
risk assessments and working practices
um perhaps i can speak to you separately
but yes i have no problem with sharing i
think
obviously town councils produce them as
well and i think the more we share and
get best practice the better well we've
done ours but i'm more concerned about
the toilets we keep getting constant
complaints about the toilets and asking
if they are being cleaned whereas when
you've produced it
you will highlighted the risk in the
areas and we can turn around and say
well this is what malden council is
doing
and they're doing the best etcetera
etcetera they can i just think it's
helpful if we all did it
together rather than everybody else is
reinventing the same wheel
thank you yes absolutely in the toilet
it's a good point um and that's why
we've got some toilets open and some
clothes at the moment because we
we uh brought in additional cleaning uh
regimes to uh
to improve the cleanliness during the
kobe crisis obviously that was based
upon a risk assessment so yes happy to
get that shared for you
thank you thank you
uh berna are there any other members no
chairman
thank you very much um mr holmes i just
want to ask
about the action plan because i assume
now it has to be quite fluid because
of covid and we we are told we will be
um in this risk
of infection for some time maybe up to a
year or longer
so i'm assuming although you've got a
time scale on a lot of these things
they're going to be fluid because we
don't know what is happening in the
future
um i think you're absolutely right i
think we do need to do a review
uh now particularly as we're coming out
perhaps what is the first phase of covid
and going to something which we may have
to live with for some months and
maybe years to come um so i think we
will do a review of that
you're absolutely right it needs to be
fluid to reflect um different risks
um and obviously um our workforce at the
moment and operating
not in the same way as they were before
um most of us are working from home
apart from some of the activities
perhaps around the parks where they're
still working
um and some other travelling offices so
yes
fluid yeah but we will take a covered
review of it i think and update it on
that basis
so at the moment then we're we're um
we have an action plan um
so that action plan we're being asked to
be approved
by this committee so the action plan
is going to be fluid then really um
if members would like to um perhaps
defer
that health and safety action plan and
we could then do the update and revisit
that and bring it back
uh updated um with our latest position
um now we've had a chance to get through
perhaps immediate crisis that might be
uh
perhaps uh suitable members we could
perhaps do that in the next meeting yes
i think that would be better um so we
will amend that
recommendation members the
recommendation little four
um to say the health and safety action
plan for 2020 to 21
um will be updated
and brought back to this committee for
approval yeah
or something like that yeah happy to do
that
yes
yes yes chairman so happy with
the wording on that and yes i'm brought
back to this committee for
for approval yes thank you very much are
our members happy with that
i agree yeah i'm changing that one so
wendy wendy wants to speak i think sorry
wendy you come in
chairman would you allow me just to ask
mr holmes to thank all his staff
especially the park
litter pickers um i think we're all a
little bit
really saddened and i'm sorry i think it
comes under health and safety because
they
they're actually working their socks off
picking up after groups of people who
are using all our facilities
and leaving copious amounts of rubbish
gas canisters etc
and chairman i think it would be really
nice if this committee
thanked mr holmes and his team because
they're the workers they're the ones on
the ground
not sitting at home in offices like what
we are and i think it would be really
nice if he could thank everybody
not degrading any officer sitting at
home so please don't fill my inbox with
anything
but i think it's really important that
they recognize mr holmes because
we have seen the state of the parks we
are getting reports of urination and
horrible defecations in areas which
they're actually
having to clean and it's really
important this council recognizes them
chairman thank you
yes i think we will agree with that
council stamp
in and also the refuse collectors who've
been outstanding
during this crisis so if we can minute
that
um berna please think think of those
kind words
so we will go back to the
recommendations members so we've got
um the accident statistics the
health and safety action plan 1920 and
information
on health and safety matters and then
we're changing the last
um part of the recommendation for it to
be
updated and brought back for approval um
so if i may have a seconder to that
please
counsel heard happy to second that
counselor heard
good thank you and members are you happy
the
remainder of the members were happy with
accepting that yes
agreed okay lovely thank you so we go on
to
agenda item 10 which is a section 106
update report um
and mr dodson is going to present this
please
thank you chairman um members this this
report provides an update to members on
progress with section 106 delivery
as requested at the last meeting of
performance governance and audit
committee
um that that meeting was back in april
and a briefing report was placed on the
mod gov library in march
um sorry that meeting was in february um
and the and
um report was due in in april
um given the covid issue um
a report was placed on the mod gov
library in view in lieu of that report
coming forward
with the resumption of of pga as a
virtual committee the briefing note has
now brought forward as appendix a to
this report
the report outlines the current work
underway and highlights the introduction
of a new section 106 reporting
requirement from december 2020
the infrastructure funding statement
will cover the first return period from
the 1st of april 2019
to the 31st of march 2020 and it will be
repeated annually after that
being due for the first time on the 31st
of december 2020
as mr andrews outlines in his report
he's undertaking reconciliation work at
present
and following the latest work is keen to
arrange a member seminar for all members
in august or september
to go through the detail of the
agreements and the status of the
projects
that will follow his comprehensive
review of the council's existing
spreadsheets and
necessary monitoring visits to ensure
that all the records
are up to date obviously there's there's
been an issue at the moment in some of
those
um visits that he's not been able to do
throughout the um
covert emergency period um
following that that seminar we will also
bring a report to this meeting towards
the end of the year
to present the infrastructure funding
statement prior to submission
um ahead of the end of the year deadline
thank you chairman
thank you mr johnson so um
members um you will note that we're
going to have this seminar which is all
members
so i don't know if there's any
particular questions that
um members would like to ask but you're
very happy to do so if there is anything
anyone berna
yes um cancer stamp would like to ask a
question
no sorry custom maze we have first
place yes is councilman's on this
committee
oh she knows she's come back and said
here here sorry it is actually comes
the stamp who's asking yeah system yes
yes thank you
thank you um could um um
mr dobson and nelly called you the
lovely mr dobson then i remembered my
place i'm terribly sorry
could mr jobson tell us when we're
actually going to have a working group
um to do with this or is it not on this
committee it's going to be still
are they not going to be along in tandem
um mr johnson
i can't hear you i can see you but i
can't hear you
sorry i i've muted while still asking
questions
um yes the sill working group has now
been
established but but hasn't met yet the
present the sill work is there's some
work going on commissioned around the
infrastructure requirement um statement
and also around the viability work there
are two pieces of work that need to be
put together
and then they will go to the working
group to discuss those as soon as as
they come back
we wouldn't normally take the section
106 through that working group it has
been established for the sill
specifically
but obviously we're keen to update
members on the the latest position with
section 106 through that that all member
seminar
because chairman we wouldn't want to
duplicate work would we
you know because it's two separate
but i'd like to say thank you for i've
never met the gentleman but hopefully we
will start to move
in the right direction of 106s because
we're all keen to get our fair share in
our communities
of what we're entitled to because i
appreciate we're at different stages of
builds
but sadly some of us have been
surrounded by building noise and it
seems like five years even though it's
most probably three years and it'd be
nice for the communities to get some
benefit back
so thank thank you thank you mr dodson i
i
take it the still working group will
report to council and not this committee
is that right that's correct chairman as
it was appointed by council
yeah correct thank you um any other
members
of schemes would like to ask a question
councillor schemes please
yes i mean uh as uh just uh reiterating
really what our council stamp said
and my concern that time is passing and
i mean i've had discussions with
officers uh that seem to be years old
now
about various facilities that were going
to be brought here by 106 and now maybe
by
sil i'm worried about the confusion
between sil
and uh 106 and i'm worried that things
might start have started falling off
uh the list and i just wasn't looking
for reassurance that everything that was
promised
uh even though the years have been
passing
and i understand transformation and then
covert 19 is interrupted
but all those things will actually be
delivered and maybe
there may be a case since such so so
much time has passed
for reviewing um uh a number
of the opportunities that maybe things
have changed
thank you mr dodson dude you want to
comment
thank you chairman yes the the the
infrastructure delivery plan outlines
the
the um delivery um elements of the the
section 106
and that's something that's a statutory
document
that will be reviewed um to look at
whether things have changed um but that
the the section 106 funding
directly delivers um projects that
address the impact of development
and the sill will be able to bring
forward
a wider range of projects that
reflect the the broader development but
not necessarily a direct
impact of each site it is much more
flexible in how it can be
addressed so we're very keen to bring
that forward but yes
the um seminar that we hold in august
will
cover the infrastructure delivery plan
and the items that were included on
there so that members can see
where we are in terms of progressing the
delivery of all of those
thank you any other member bernard
yes councillor stamp would ask live to
ask another question uh
counselor stamp just a quick one please
mr johnston it won't be at the expense
of things that's already been agreed
under the section 106 will it so when we
have the meeting and the training
session in august
that and talking about the legal
agreements legal agreements
they will still stand won't they so for
example cancer skins was mentioned in
things in burnham on crouch
we'd actually ask for funding towards a
uh bmx
park uh behind the marina now we we
actually did
he did a hell of a lot a heck of a lot
of work and we actually put a lot in as
well so we are really really looking
forward to have that money in that
facility
and that was agreed before the
transformation
and we as councillors are and i think
this is what cancer schemes was alluding
to
we're concerned we're going to be losing
out if you're now going to try and
change
to incorporate the still as well could
you reassure us that we are going to get
what we've been promised before
the the sales shouldn't impact at all on
the infrastructure delivery plan that's
already set out for section 106
and as i said those those items within
there are directly related to the
delivery
of the housing that's in in the ldp so
there's absolutely no reason why that
should change
um and you you shouldn't um
those projects shouldn't be delivered
thank you
all right thank you any other member
benner yes councillor swain has a
question chairman that's the swain
yes thank you madam chairman um in the
first place
um i thought we've got the seminars
coming up i wonder whether there can be
some clarification of the relationship
uh between the infrastructure delivery
plan
and the infrastructure funding statement
um secondly is this uh
an area for strategy and resources
rather than
pga or will it is it really for full
council
um and lastly the
write-up for this um talks about a
narrative
um for i think for the infrastructure
funding statement
yet surely we need to have um
details of what
is included and how what how they are
funded
because if we have to come up with a
funding gap then we need to know
where the money's come from and what we
are hoping to put it towards
it's a question of how much detail will
go into these statements
or whether we just have general
overarching
uh not very helpful comments
well if i may cancel swain um as far as
this committee is concerned we are about
performance so the section 106 was about
how we were performing
in delivering the items that were
under that section 106. the funding
and this financial statement will go to
council i
i guess um as will the seminar be for
all members
is that correct mr johnson
mr johnson yes yes i'm sorry i was just
switching on
um yes the seminar as you say will be
for all members
um chairman the um i don't believe the
infrastructure funding statement
requires council sign off as such
um so it could come here in terms of
reporting it will be reporting on
the um the performance in effect that's
what the the funding statement is
it's a statement to government regarding
the delivery
of the infrastructure delivery plan so
it would be appropriate for it to come
here
it's just that it is termed
infrastructure financial
statement that's the confusion i think
yes i think it's it's that that's how
it's um
described but it is about the delivery
of section 106
projects all right okay thank you
are you clear on that way this should
await the seminars
good okay all right any other
member berna no that concludes the
questions
okay thank you so members we'll move to
the recommendations
three little recommendations um so we
know the
in infrastructure financial statement is
going to come back to this committee
and the seminar will be for all members
so we're just really noting those and
the briefing report
so may i have a seconder to those three
little recommendations can you put your
is there
i think we've got various sections how
many i've got my face on the screen
okay counselor channel i'm taking us the
second one thank you very much
okay all members happy with that recruit
okay very much so we move on then to
item 11 which is any other items of
business
chairman decides are urgent i'd be
pleased to know that i have none
so at whatever time it is and i don't
have a
clock 302 1502
we're going to close the meeting so if
you make sure
you go out to the meeting don't go into
chat and
talk and thank you so very much everyone
thank you to all of you especially to
all the officers that have attended and
to all the hard work that they've done